It totally seems to you,
uh.
Displaced when the reproach is made,
uh, also, when I say you,
the insubordinates,
uh. From sometimes, uh.
Biting on the line,
when, uh.
Rima Hassan,
for example,
who is on the list, uh.
Said it was true that Hamas was carrying out 1 action
legitimate,
didn't you say that yourself,
she didn't say that,
she didn't say that ?
Rima Hassan is therefore our
candidate on the European list.
On nine/06,
I remind you,
it will be necessary,
it will be necessary to go to vote very massively.
We are very proud that she is on our list.
This is 1 lawyer
specialist in migration issues,
who speaks the language of law
international,
who herself founded an observatory on the
refugees,
since she has herself,
she was born
and she lived for 10 years in 1 camp of
refugees.
So we're very proud that she's on our list.
What she talked about,
it's legitimacy
recognized by 2 UN resolutions,
the legitimacy to resist for 1 people
when it is in 1
colonization or apartment situation.
It's just
this reference to resolutions of law
it is enough to provoke a lot of reactions,
including on the left.
Raphael,
since it was revolting,
Fabien Roussel,
it is complicated to rise from its positions.
It will be the debate of the European elections too